so you were on the set with us yes who
came out I remember I remember I
remember I was really stressed out
because you guys were there and I had
just received uh I guess a page of
dialogue it wasn't scripted he's like
here you got to go say this I was like
we just put on these wetsuits right
right suffocating from that I remember I
was all stressed out for our interview
oh no you words maybe should be video
eventually Trey great yeah I don't know
it's like it's like you're bringing up a
lot of like trauma oh no I didn't want
to do that I mean that's that this it
was the coolest thing ever it was the
best part Detroit right we were in
Detroit and to see it now all together
it's kind of it is kind of mind-blowing
right coming I haven't seen it yet well
see it's more like you're in the film I
am in it you are Phil how did you find
out you were going to be back I mean he
took a little vacation the last one
right lieutenant
and it's Lennox how did you find out
you're going to be part of this film I
got a call from mark variety and asking
if I wanted to you know what I was doing
for that summer I was like you guys want
me back yeah because I had like written
you guys off without help we broke up
and we need you guys anymore
take a timeout and then I was like oh
yes I'll take you back I'll take you
back so that's kind of the way when I
was really I was because there's there's
a there's an energy there's a there's an
enthusiasm there's a sense of I don't
know what it is but there's a sense of
like constant emergency or desperation
Elise yes just to get the day done and
to get the job done and and there's
something addicting about that I love it
and I love that these big these big ward
battle scenes that we get to do and so I
was excited to go back yeah it but
you've been part of it since the
beginning working with Michael Bay and
you were there with them for the
Hollywood star that's yeah what does he
mean to you it's a it's a really
interesting relationship there really is
because I feel like I've become a good
friend to him yeah you know the guy's
intense
fraid to light me up when I did when I
deserve but then he turns around and
he'll be joking with me to us later so
I'm like what you didn't like me but you
do oh you do like me so it's it's it's
like that but I also feel in this one I
felt a lot more comfortable with him I
felt like I could ask questions whereas
before I was probably didn't want to get
his ways I always got stuff going on but
I wasn't afraid to be like wait wait
wait wait wait what are we I'm not sure
what we're doing here are we are we
fifteen thousand feet above sea level
or are we two thousand feet below sea
level
yeah just tell me that right and we need
to know I mean you know we're all
wondering out here yeah so I was the guy
that went in they'd send me in to ask
the question go do it and bring back the
in tow oh do you have transformers at
home I do I do
I mean I would I got a four-year-old on
this for you are well he's three yo
before at the end of August great uh so
he loves this okay yeah are you gonna
give him like a transformer theme party
no I mean you could probably bring
Optimus Prime to it's part of we could
you could did even did does Michael Bay
even let you touch the cards no no tell
me again isn't he with you it's like a
kid with a giant sandbox with all the
best toys and doesn't want anybody else
to play with them friends well like I
said Ricky we're friends but you know
he's still very possessive over his
stuff I now that you haven't seen this
build but how would you describe this
film in one word from your experience
crazy this is a crazy movie to make in a
lot of different ways and it was but I
mean that the best says the word crazy
it's crazy crazy